welcome back to new rockstars I'm Eric
Boston our kid with spider-man far from
home which just came out a year ago this
month and left us with the most
immediate cliffhanger for the future of
the MCU as well as the future of however
the hell Sony expects us to pronounce
this because as we learned in our recent
wimpy episode of big question these
recent spider-man films occupy at least
two universes in this vast spider-verse
the MCU proper and a weird adjunct
suburb of it where the Sony villains
like venom and carnage and Morbius live
based on visual clues in far from home
and updates from Sony it is looking
possible that venom could play a
critical role in the plot of spider-man
3 in a way that we haven't thought of
before I'm gonna explain this venom
spider-man crossover we might be looking
at and thanks to privacy comm for
sponsoring this episode if you sign up
now by at privacy comm slash new rock
stars you can get $5 today to use on any
purchase online earlier this year
production delays caused the releases of
all the MCU titles to change Doctor
Strange in the multiverse of madness in
Thor for more clark moved from may 2021
in november 20 21 respectively back to
the first quarter of 2022 now me Tom
Hollands spider-man 3 also moved but not
in sync with these other MCU titles this
movie moved from July 2021 which was in
between Doctor Strange 2 and Thor 4
originally back but only to November
2021 now before these other two movies
suggesting that this movie's plot line
won't be that interconnected with these
MCU plots and might instead be more
connected to venom let there be carnage
now scheduled directly before spider-man
3 in June 20 21 and 1/2 know it those
final minutes of spider-man far from
home did sneak in what we later realized
was a very cryptic Easter Egg to the
spider-man and venom comics see
spider-man director Jon Watts loves
hiding comic book Easter eggs on the
license plates in his movies nearly
every visible license plate is a nod to
a specific comic book issue that
reflects what's going on in this moment
of the movies story so on Tower Bridge
in London we noticed two license plates
that do this one that reads 2865
s AP a nod to amazing spider-man issue
28 released in 1965 September in which
spider-man fights molten man
and similar to the fiery elemental
Mysterio projection Peter faced in
Prague and then at the end of the scene
an upside-down car tagged TAS M 143 now
to the amazing spider-man issue 143 in
which Peter faces cyclone similar to the
air elemental Mysterio projection in
this battle but also the issue in which
Peter and MJ yes as they do in the scene
but between those two license plates is
another more mysterious one throughout
this bridge battle is this blue BMW that
appears again and again and it is tagged
m95 x lb now sure there are some other
cars on this bridge so you can kind of
see they're just background once they
have random license tags but this one
has to be specific because XLV is the
Roman numeral for 45 and this is all a
reference to the astonishing spider-man
number 45 the debut of xi venom but the
problem is unlike all those other
license tag Easter eggs in these movies
XI venom really has nothing to do with
this scene and you could say the code
isn't complete ydm well I believe the
Shi venom M is a deliberate clue pointed
at how they follow up to this film will
introduce Peter to XI venom Michelle but
not Michelle Williams and Wayne at XI
venom from the brief scene in the Tom
Hardy venom film but Michelle Jones MJ
now if the idea of zendaya HD venom in
this third film sounds less interesting
to you than say Peter dealing with the
sinister six or Kraven the hunter or any
of the other interesting host options
for the Venom symbiote don't worry my
theory for this sticks this goo
everywhere but before we continue we are
all stuck at home so we're continuing to
shop online and if you're like me you're
also spending these days trying to
support small businesses but for some of
these businesses I'm still a little
unsure about the safety or reliability
of their websites and that's is why I
use a privacy card to reduce my risk and
again thanks to privacy for sponsoring
this video see privacy lets you make
online purchases using virtual burner
cards this protects your identity and
bank information on the internet and it
lets you control the limits on each
virtual card you can connect directly to
your bank account with confidence
privacy comes in handy with the
streaming services or video conferencing
apps and we're all using right now so
for example I've set up an account with
privacy I've linked my bank account and
I created a card specifically for my
monthly Netflix subscription payment
privacy will ding you with
lightning-fast precision if someone
tries to charge the card twice
soare if the card exceeds the amount you
set for it no vendor can overcharge
beyond the limit that you've set it's
simple it's fast it's really just one
click privacy also lets you safely send
a burner card to a friend or a family
members straight from your dashboard
help out mom that poor lady who loves
getting hacked head to privacy comm
slash new rock starts and sign up for an
account and as a special treat for my
viewers new customers will automatically
get five dollars to spend on your first
purchase for a limited time only that's
free money just go to privacy comm slash
new rock stars and sign up now okay one
thing we don't discuss enough about
these recent spider-man movies is that
generous they are with the screen time
for the guys in the chair neither I'm
coming nor far from home are singular
Peter Parker stories they're really
ensemble pieces that showcase all of
Peters classmates head MJ flash Betty
Jason
Zack his teacher mr. Harrington Brad we
get to know these supporting players of
Peters world better than most other MCU
films supporting cast which is why it's
so interesting how far from home leaves
most of them in strangely unresolved
States Peter and MJ have started dating
but their love swing abruptly ends when
Peter is outed to the world as a
criminal we get to see MJ's reaction for
that Flash Thompson is going through
some emotional issues with absentee
parents Ned and Betty randomly break up
and then there's Brad who is scolded and
humiliated for trying to expose Peter
with some awkward naked shots he took of
them gotta stop doing it okay it is
weird I'm just saying all this denying
Brad's reality making him think he's
crazy it's kind of gas lighting that
drives kids to dirt corners of the
Internet by the way welcome back to the
rock stars I'm Eric Lawson I believe you
Brad now Ned and MJ know the truth about
Peter they know that Mysterio's daily
bugle video was a lie MJ just gave Peter
a big smooch I don't think that's the
last one that Peter will get from her so
back to that she venom Easter egg in
venom the way that the symbiote passed
from and back to Eddy was through a
similar smooch by this logic denim could
be considered a sexually transmitted
infection and also remember in venom and
an eddy discuss his past in New York the
data clue incident Wow really incident
maybe you were run out of New York I
went she went out of San Francisco no I
still have car see me or now yes the
Daily Globe is not the Daily Bugle but
Eddie's remaining currency in New York
could be connections with another fringe
journalist Jay jonah Jameson at the
Daily Bugle dotnet that could bring
Eddie Brock and his gooey STI back to
New York City after his battle with
carnage and venom - let there be carnage
and he's gonna find a city in the midst
of a manhunt for Peter Parker a manhunt
that i theorize could be led by Kraven
the hunter or Norman Osborn in the
sinister six some combination of these
figures and when Eddie tracks Peter down
the Venom symbiote recognizes Peters
power detaches from Eddie and then uses
to Peter enabling Peter to embrace his
embattled dark side and take vengeance
on his enemies a kind of reverse boner
and transfer from the comics this time
from Eddie to Peter but I don't believe
this toxic infection will end with Peter
see the real danger will be what happens
when this kind of sickness spreads via
smoochy to those in Peter's social
circle like MJ as the Michelle Shiva
gnam clue hinted and then to all of the
young folks these movies had been about
since the beginning venom flash then I'm
Betty
then am Ned assuming these kids will be
college-age for the third film I mean
all kinds of experimentation happens
those years everything travels fast like
there was one kid with mono in my dorm
and then 48 hours later it was like the
movie Contagion
which is the joke we made in 2011 not
anymore it's real and so after the
symbiote makes the rounds I think it
will settle on the host with the most
unresolved animosity toward Peter Parker
who would be the most pissed off at
Peter Peter Parker a kid flipped back
into Midtown high
steel and all the Thunder up ending the
social hierarchy just feeling
girlfriend's with his stupid charm turn
everyone against the rifle alpha and
then getting away with it yeah that is
my impression of the inner monologue of
Brad Brad I think Brad is gonna stalk
Peter to their campus bell tower we're
dripping down from those rafters will be
a symbiote goo and then he'll forget to
wash his hands when he gets home
that is folks venom in the world of
spider-man targeting Peter Parker from
the true--but arrival of his social
level and threatening this small
community of lovable nerds at the heart
of the franchise
join this conversation on discord by the
committee patreon at patreon.com slash
new rock stars follow me on instagram @
EA vas follow new rock stars and
subscribe and in the words of
spider-man's biggest enemy
[Music]